una alternativa realmente es mejor que otra,
pero somos demasiado tontos para saber cuál es,
y como no sabemos cuál es, podríamos también
tomar la opción menos arriesgada.
Incluso tomando dos alternativas lado a lado
con información total, la decisión aún puede ser difícil.
Las elecciones difíciles lo son
no por nosotros o por nuestra ignorancia;
son difíciles porque no hay una opción que sea mejor.
Ahora, si no hay una opción que sea mejor,
si las escalas no favorecen a una alternativa
sobre la otra,
entonces las alternativas deben ser igualmente buenas,
y quizá lo correcto sea decir que las elecciones difíciles
se dan entre opciones igualmente buenas.
Eso no puede ser correcto.
Si las alternativas son igualmente buenas,
uno debería arrojar una moneda.
Y parece erróneo pensar
que esa sea la forma de decidir entre carreras,
lugares para vivir, personas para casarse: arrojar una moneda.
Hay otra razón para pensar
que las elecciones difíciles no se dan
entre opciones igualmente buenas.
Supongamos que tienen que elegir entre dos empleos:
pueden ser banqueros de inversión
o artistas gráficos.
Hay muchas cosas que importan en esa elección,
como el entusiasmo por el trabajo,
lograr seguridad financiera,
tener tiempo para formar una familia, etc.
Quizá la carrera de artista los ponga
a la vanguardia de las nuevas formas
de expresión pictórica.
Quizá la carrera bancaria
los ponga a la vanguardia
de nuevas formas de manipulación financiera.
No obstante, imaginen los dos empleos
de modo que ninguno es mejor que el otro.
Ahora, supongamos que mejoramos uno un poco.
Supongamos que el banco nos corteja,
añade USD 500 al mes a su salario.
El dinero extra ¿hace al empleo en el banco
mejor que el del artista?
No necesariamente.
Un salario más alto hace al empleo en el banco
mejor que antes,
pero puede que no sea suficiente para
hacerlo mejor que ser artista.
Pero si una mejora en uno de los empleos
no lo hace mejor que el otro,
entonces los dos empleos del principio
no eran igualmente buenos.
Si uno parte de dos cosas igualmente buenas,
y mejora una de ellas,
ahora debe ser mejor que la otra.
Ese no es el caso de las opciones en elecciones difíciles.
Por eso tenemos un rompecabezas.
Tenemos dos empleos.
Ninguno mejor que el otro,
pero tampoco igualmente buenos.
¿Cómo se supone que elegiremos?
Algo parece no estar bien aquí.
Quizá la opción en sí es problemática
y la comparación es imposible.
Pero eso no puede ser correcto.
No estamos tratando de elegir entre
dos cosas que no pueden compararse.
Después de todo, estamos sopesando los méritos de dos empleos
no los méritos del número 9
con respecto a un plato de huevos fritos.
Una comparación de los méritos generales de dos empleos
es algo que podemos hacer,
y algo que hacemos a menudo.
Pienso que el rompecabezas surge
por un supuesto irreflexivo
que hacemos de los valores.
Sin querer, suponemos que los valores
como la justicia, la belleza, la bondad,
son similares a las cantidades científicas,
como la longitud, la masa y el peso.
Tomen cualquier pregunta comparativa que no implique valores,
tal como ¿cuál de las dos maletas es más pesada?
Hay solo tres posibilidades:
el peso de una es mayor, menor
o igual al peso de la otra.
Las propiedades como el peso se pueden representar
con números reales, uno, dos, tres, etc.
y hay solo tres comparaciones posibles
entre dos números reales.
Un número es mayor, menor,
o igual a otro.
No es así con los valores.
Como criaturas de la post Ilustración,
solemos suponer
que el pensamiento científico es la clave
de todo lo importante en nuestro mundo,
pero el mundo de los valores
es diferente al mundo de la ciencia.
Las cosas de un mundo
pueden ser cuantificadas por los números reales.
Las cosas del otro mundo no pueden.
No deberíamos suponer
que el mundo de las longitudes y los pesos,
tiene la misma estructura que el mundo del deber,
o de lo que debemos hacer.
Por eso, lo que nos importa,
el deleite de un niño, el amor por la pareja,
no puede representarse con números reales,
luego no hay razón para creer
que en la elección solo hay tres posibilidades:
una alternativa es mejor, peor o igual
que la otra.
Necesitamos una cuarta relación más allá
del mejor, peor o igual
que describa lo que ocurre en las elecciones difíciles.
Me gusta decir que las alternativas están
al mismo nivel.
Cuando las alternativas están al mismo nivel,
puede importar mucho la que uno elija,
pero una alternativa no es mejor que la otra.
Más bien, las alternativas están
en el mismo radio en cuanto a valor,
en la misma liga en cuanto a valor,
mientras que al mismo tiempo son muy distintas
en tipo de valor.
Por eso la elección es difícil.
Entender así las elecciones difíciles
nos descubre algo sobre nosotros que no conocíamos.
Cada uno de nosotros tiene el poder
de crear razones.
Imaginen un mundo en el que cada elección que enfrentásemos
fuese fácil,
o sea, siempre existe la mejor alternativa.
De existir una mejor alternativa,
es la que uno debería elegir,
porque parte de ser racional
es hacer lo mejor, en vez de lo peor
al elegir lo que uno puede fundamentar mejor.
En un mundo así,
tendríamos más razones
para usar calcetines negros en vez de rosados,
de comer cereales en vez de donuts,
de vivir en la ciudad en vez de vivir en el campo,
de casarnos con Betty en vez de hacerlo con Lolita.
Un mundo lleno de elecciones fáciles
nos haría esclavos de la razón.
Si lo piensan,
es de locos creer
que las razones dadas
determinarán que hay más razón en seguir
los pasatiempos exactos para uno,
la casa exacta para uno,
el empleo exacto para uno.
En cambio, uno enfrenta alternativas
que estaban al mismo nivel, elecciones difíciles,
y uno encontró razones propias
para elegir ese pasatiempo, esa casa y ese empleo.
Cuando las alternativas están al mismo nivel,
las razones dadas, las que
determinan si estamos cometiendo un error,
guardan silencio en cuanto a qué hacer.
Es aquí, en el espacio de las elecciones difíciles
que tenemos que ejercitar
nuestro poder normativo,
el poder de crear las propias razones,
para hacer de uno mismo
el tipo de persona
para quien la vida rural
es preferible a la vida urbana.
Cuando elegimos entre
opciones que están al mismo nivel,
podemos hacer algo bastante notable.
Podemos alinearnos detrás de una opción.
Aquí me posiciono.
Este soy yo. Me gusta la banca.
Me gustan los donuts de chocolate.
Esta respuesta en las elecciones difíciles
es una respuesta racional,
pero no responde a razones dadas.
Más bien, se apoya en razones creadas por nosotros.
Cuando creamos razones para nosotros,
para ser este tipo de personas en vez de otro,
nos convertimos totalmente en las personas que somos.
Se podría decir que llegamos a ser los autores
de nuestras propias vidas.
Cuando enfrentamos elecciones difíciles,
no deberíamos darnos con la cabeza en la pared
tratando de averiguar qué alternativa es mejor.
No existe la mejor alternativa.
En vez de buscar las razones fuera,
deberíamos buscar las razones dentro:
¿Quién quiero ser?
Puedo decidir usar calcetines rosados,
amar los cereales, ser banquero rural,
y puedo decidir usar calcetines negros,
y ser artista urbano, amante de los donuts.
Lo que hagamos ante las elecciones difíciles
depende mucho de nosotros.
Ahora, las personas que no ejercen su poder normativo en elecciones difíciles
van a la deriva.
Todos conocemos personas así.
Yo fui a la deriva en abogacía.
No puse mi determinación en la abogacía.
La abogacía no era lo mío.
Quienes van a la deriva dejan que el mundo
escriba la historia de sus vidas.
Permiten que los mecanismos de recompensas y castigos,
las palmaditas en la cabeza, el miedo, la facilidad de una opción,
determinen quiénes son.
Por eso, la lección de las elecciones difíciles
se refleja dónde uno pone la determinación,
en lo que uno decide apoyar,
y, mediante elecciones difíciles,
se vuelve esa persona.
Lejos de ser fuente de agonía y terror,
las elecciones difíciles son oportunidades preciosas
para celebrar lo especial
de la condición humana,
que las razones que rigen nuestras elecciones
sean correctas o incorrectas
a veces se agotan,
y es aquí, en el espacio de elecciones difíciles,
que tenemos el poder
de crear las propias razones
para volvernos las personas singulares que somos.
Y por eso las elecciones difíciles no son una maldición,
sino un regalo del cielo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)